a la derecha el instituto jackman de
rivia kilos en la isla territorial
francesa de martinica a la izquierda en
institutos anti exúpery en la comunidad
en yoga en la francia continental dos
aulas y dos enfoques distintos de la
educación sobre la esclavitud es los
esclavizados venían de áfrica entre 300
y 400 eran encadenados en el casco del
barco donde hacía calor show un pedazo
de historia oscuro y esencial que debe
ser enseñado y discutido con las
próximas generaciones para no olvidar
nunca lo que sufrieron los hombres y
mujeres esclavizados en francia cuando
hacemos nuestra vida cotidiana olvidamos
que la esclavitud existió aquí en
martinica los alumnos repasan antes de
un examen poniendo a prueba sus
conocimientos de las condiciones en que
los esclavizados fueron llevados a las
antillas desde áfrica
los esclavizados eran traídos en la
carga del barco no tenían mucho espacio
es más no les alimentaban mucho y eran
tratados como bestias como animales al
otro lado del atlántico los alumnos de
3º del instituto sanger super y en el
continente francés discuten el tema de
la esclavitud
a través de lo que han aprendido de la
radio las obras de teatro y los poemas
un día la historia los recordará puede
ser a través de libros ilustrados con
justicia y respeto después de tanto
dolor discreta es la esclavitud es un
periodo que nunca debemos olvidar porque
todavía existe y si existe to you is la
historia es la memoria y también es lo
que construye nuestra sociedad si es una
mente abierta nos impide cerrarnos de ir
hacia los extremos yo les digo a mis
alumnos que debemos estar abiertos de
intentar comprender el pasado para ver
el presente de otra manera uno empezó la
esclavitud colonial y el tráfico de
esclavizados pasaron a formar parte de
los planes de estudios nacionales y se
integraron en los libros de texto cuando
se adoptó la ley atómica el 10 de mayo
de 2001